[Music]
on this friday night a vicious attack on
a british mp
conservative lawmaker sir david amos
stabbed to death while meeting with
constituents and today he was simply
dispensing his duties when his life was
horrifically cut short what police are
saying about the suspect and the
possible motive giving afghanistan girls
hope for the future i don't know what
we've done if
we stayed jeff semple is in islamabad
tonight with families who fled the
taliban take over what's being done to
help them and those left behind
fully vaccinated canadians can mark
their calendars for land travel to the
u.s but will america accept those with
mixed doses between a rock and a hard
place
could a rare mineral in greenland help
solve some of the world's climate
problems
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in the uk where
parliamentarians are reeling after a
horrific attack on one of their own
in southern england sir david amos one
of the longest-serving mps in british
parliament was killed while carrying out
his public duties he was stabbed to
death during a meeting with local
constituents
a 25-year-old man is now in custody
suspected of murder redmond shannon is
in the town of lee on c with tonight's
top story on the investigation and
what's known about the potential motive
mp david amos likes to meet voters in
all parts of his constituency this
friday he welcomed people to the local
methodist church but around midday a man
reportedly walked in and stabbed amos
multiple times tragically he died at the
scene a 25 year old man was arrested
immediately at the scene on suspicion of
murder
he remains in custody
a knife was also recovered at the scene
police say they are keeping an open mind
on the motive and are not ruling out
terrorism nothing about today makes
sense at all melanie harris says the mp
of 38 years was well known around her
coastal town he was always so welcoming
accommodating friendly approachable
and restored your faith in politics like
made you feel that you had a voice in
your constituency he was so warm and so
inviting he had me come to his offices
in london on numerous occasions reverend
steve tinning says amos a conservative
mp had helped him reunite syrian refugee
families in the area this attack echoes
three similar incidents in the uk over
the past 21 years including the 2016
murder of opposition labor mp joe cox
just as she was about to meet with
constituents in the north of england
that killing was just days before the
divisive brexit referendum in which cox
campaigned for the uk to stay in the eu
her killer yelled nationalist slogans
during the attack it's so hard because
we've got a job to do and i find myself
now
you know working as a politician and
trying to help people and trying to do
good things for people but this is the
risk amos was a lifelong tory and
staunch social conservative but it's not
clear whether politics played a role in
his killing voters here expressing worry
about the effect this latest deadly
violence could have we don't want to
lose them face-to-face contact with
those that represent us in the highest
powers of parliament is really important
but clearly safety has to take a higher
priority because we can't be here again
counter-terrorism police are now leading
the investigation redmond shannon leon c
england
before his death david amos wrote a book
that reflected on the 2016 murder of joe
cox and how because of security concerns
mps have had to change the way they
interact with voters
in eyes and ears a survivor's guide to
westminster amos wrote we all make
ourselves readily available to our
constituents and are often dealing with
members of the public who have mental
health problems
it could happen to any of us we
regularly check our locks and many
others have cctv cameras installed
it was also a deadly day in afghanistan
at least 47 people died after suicide
bombers attacked a shiite mosque packed
with worshippers
three people attacked the mosque in
kandahar just as friday prayers ended at
least 70 people were injured friday is
the holiest day for muslims last week
there was another deadly attack at a
packed shiite mosque during friday
prayers
the fate of women and girls in
afghanistan is also cause for major
concern taliban leaders are vowing to
respect them despite a history of
oppression but human rights groups and
those who have fled the country paint a
far gloomier picture of the future jeff
sample reports from islamabad pakistan
in afghanistan or anywhere else for that
matter this is an unusual site
men wearing burqas marching through the
streets of kabul part of a protest back
in 2015 calling for equal rights for
afghan women and among the crowd was
basir bita people
who hold high positions
they don't really work for women's
rights they just pretend that they are
working
the married father works for a
non-profit called canadian women for
women in afghanistan the group is partly
funded by the canadian government and
has promoted women's education in
afghanistan for 25 years bita's own
daughter was set to graduate from high
school this year i won't become a doctor
i'm not sure
but that's one of my choices but those
plans were interrupted when the taliban
took over despite pledges to uphold
women's rights girls secondary schools
remain closed many working women have
been told to stay home we're still in
this very murky period the head of the
canadian women's education group says
while schools are closed their ngo
remains operational offering courses to
women and girls in their homes remotely
because we were already doing virtual
and distance learning in afghanistan and
so people can still access our materials
you know from phones and computers
people are waiting to find out what's
going to be allowed and not allowed but
others aren't waiting
this family part of afghanistan's
persecuted hazara minority fled to
pakistan
muhammad ishaq saw the taliban coming
and dragging hazara girls from their
homes he told his daughters to escape
out the back door
[Music]
they left without their sandals he says
when the taliban came in they asked
where are your children i told them i
didn't have any children but they saw
all the sandals they called me a liar
and pushed me down he says i fell and
broke my wrist
they're now living in this un funded
safe house with seven other families
the taliban declared they will take
hazara girls as their jihadi brides she
says we fled the country so our children
can have a brighter future
after several failed attempts bita's
family also managed to escape to
islamabad his daughter mejia just heard
her friends some as young as 13 are now
getting married off it's weird my friend
who's younger than me she's getting
engaged and
i don't know
i think that's how it's going to be
after this she misses her friends but
wants to continue her education
finishing high school and starting
university
the family has just been approved to
come to canada i got lucky and
i don't know what i've done if
we stayed the taliban says the girls
schools are closed temporarily as it
works to reform the curriculum though
that's exactly what the group said when
it took power the first time in 1996
and the schools never reopened
pharah
jeff semple in islamabad pakistan thank
you jeff
a top commander with the canadian
military is making the case to get his
job back admiral art mcdonald
voluntarily stepped aside as chief of
the defense staff after an allegation of
sexual assault surfaced general wayne
ayer has been acting as the country's
top military official ever since
now global news has obtained a copy of a
letter sent by mcdonald to top officers
as david aiken reports mcdonald claims
he's been cleared and should be
reinstated
the three-page letter signed by admiral
art mcdonald is addressed to the
military's generals and flag officers
about 140 people and in it mcdonald
refers to the allegation of sexual
assault made against him as quote
refuted
unsubstantiated and my exoneration that
may be mcdonald's opinion but his
exoneration is still at issue admiral
art mcdonald was not exonerated by the
military police
they were very careful in their report
nonetheless mcdonald says that if he
cannot resume his duties as chief of
defense staff that would mean attempts
to change the military's culture when it
comes to women and sexual misconduct
will be set back
to avoid undermining the principles that
must be foundational to legitimate
cultural change this means seeing my
immediate return to duty he also
criticized the prime minister the
government and the department of
national defense for how it is handling
his case even as he boasted about his
own behavior i have acted with the
integrity and compassion that you would
expect of your admiral therefore i
assert that my leadership is now proven
stronger than ever defense minister
harjit sajan said mcdonald's letter was
quote inappropriate and unacceptable and
in a statement to global news he said in
canada civilians provide necessary
oversight of the military and decide who
is best suited to lead the armed forces
mcdonald's email does not reflect this
nor does it reflect the need to put
survivors and victims of sexual
misconduct first and the acting chief of
the defense staff general wayne ayer
took a similar tone saying mcdonald's
shocking letter changes nothing with
respect to our vital work of defending
our nation changing our culture and
preparing for the threats ahead
and the complainant her name is navy
lieutenant heather mcdonald and she was
already feeling let down by the system
back in august when investigators said
they would file no charges against the
admiral she told global news that she
felt like she'd been punched in the
stomach that she'd gone through hell for
nothing
it was one thing that admiral mcdonald's
investigation ended with no charges but
this three-page letter from the admiral
well it's a different matter say
military experts and some victims they
say the admiral's grievances and his
tone may make it more difficult for
future victims to come forward pharah
david aiken in ottawa thank you david
there is a major update tonight on the
water crisis in ikaluit the city says
test results have come back showing
exceedingly high concentrations of fuel
components in a tank that supplies water
to the capital residents were warned
tuesday not to drink the water the
nunavut government has shipped in water
to help residents have also been drawing
water from a nearby river an
investigation is now underway but
officials suspect contaminants from the
soil or groundwater somehow got into the
tank the city says it's flushing its
water distribution system
bc's decline loops to schwetmick first
nation says prime minister justin
trudeau will visit on monday the trip to
kamloops follows trudeau's apology for
not responding to two invitations to
visit on september 30th the first
national day for truth and
reconciliation
instead he spent the day on a bc beach
with his wife
and we now have a firm date for when
prime minister justin trudeau will name
his new cabinet the announcement is set
for october 26th and parliament will
return on november 22nd and there's
another date to mark on your calendar if
you're hoping to travel to the u.s by
land monday november 8th is set for the
reopening off the border to fully
vaccinated non-essential travelers a
negative covet-19 test will not be
required to enter the u.s by land but it
is needed to return to canada
and for those canadians who have mixed
vaccine doses you will be allowed to
cross into the united states late today
the u.s center for disease control
confirmed people who have had a
combination of vaccines approved by the
who will be considered fully vaccinated
canadians traveling into the u.s by air
or land will have to be prepared to
provide proof off their vaccination
status former u.s president bill clinton
is recovering in hospital after being
admitted for an infection doctors say
the 75 year old has a urological
infection that spread to his bloodstream
and he's responding well to treatment
clinton's spokesperson says he's in good
spirits
royally irritated coming up the queen is
caught on camera criticizing world
leaders
an upcoming global climate summit will
be missing the world's largest
greenhouse gas emitter reports suggest
chinese president xi jinping will not
attend the cop 26 conference in person
glasgow is hosting the united nations
summit starting at the end of the month
britain hopes to spur climate action at
the talks but there are reports that she
told british prime minister boris
johnson he won't be there
and ahead of that same summit queen
elizabeth was caught in a candid
conversation thursday slamming world
leaders for inaction on their promises
to fight climate change
[Music]
during the conversation the monarch was
also overheard voicing frustration over
leaders who were not attending the cop
26 summit the queen will be there she's
not the only royal frustrated about
inaction on climate change in a bbc
interview this week prince william took
a swipe at the billionaire space race
saying the world's greatest minds should
be fixed on trying to repair this planet
not trying to find the next place
still had the backlash over an effort to
make blood donation more inclusive in
two canadian cities
canadian blood services says it's taking
a step forward to be more inclusive it's
now expanding eligibility for some gay
men to donate plasma at select clinics
despite that many are still unable to
donate blood due to old health canada
restrictions as michael couture reports
advocates say this new step is nowhere
near the change they want to see from
ottawa
there's lots of reasons to donate blood
that's why we need donors every day
the need is constant but the eligibility
continues to be constrained since 1992
gay men in canada have been limited in
how they can give the gift of life
a personal and professional challenge
for calgary paramedic glendale miguel my
own values tell me that i can't be a
part of a system that discriminates
individuals especially like myself yet i
understand the importance of the
life-saving necessity for these products
changes to the system in 2019 required
gay and bisexual men to avoid sex with
other men for three months before
donating blood but it was still a
barrier others didn't have to deal with
this september canadian blood services
began allowing plasma donations miguel
was one of the first to take part in the
pilot project where screening questions
focused on his sexual behavior rather
than his sexual orientation
all the staff showed a lot of support
and enthusiasm for change and and to be
honest most of them actually mentioned
that this change itself does not go far
enough the trudeau government has
committed to removing the blood donation
ban in a statement health minister patty
haidew said we anticipate receiving a
submission from canadian blood services
later this year in order for them to
implement a more inclusive
behavior-based screening for all blood
donors but long-time advocate and lawyer
doug elliott says the government could
have and should have done it a long time
ago instead they let people suffer who
need our rare blood types because they
don't want to court political
controversy and i think that's tragic
community activists agree and say this
latest move is just a small step forward
they're going to look forward to when we
actually have
an end to the blood ban and really that
equal application of screening for all
donors a move that would not only
address an inequality but could help
fill the desperate need for more donors
mike lacouter global news ottawa
next the rock that geologists say could
help save our planet
[Music]
a type of rock could be key to solving
the world's climate problems according
to some geologists it's called
anorthocyte and other than on the moon
it's only been discovered in a remote
arctic region on this planet as eric
sorensen explains the rare mineral has
caught the attention of everyone from
mining companies to nasa
as greenland watches its great glaciers
melt from climate change the government
decided this year it will no longer
license oil and gas exploration but it
believes there is extraction in
greenland that will actually help the
climate
workers here are studying deposits of
anorthocyte a light-colored rock deemed
climate-friendly as it contains only
calcium silica and alumina you find it
in canada you find it in
in scandinavia russia but here is very
unique because it's so pure in
and
depleted from the elements that is
undesired from the industry it is a more
sustainable source for aluminum and can
have a smaller environmental impact on
many things we use in daily life we have
a very good quality for fiberglass we'll
also use it for fillers for paint and
ceramics one canadian company hudson
resources already mines unorthosite
deposits in greenland's white mountain
saying the mineral reduces the energy
needed to make fiberglass by 10 to 15
percent it's a huge energy saver
when it comes to making fiberglass but
also makes cleaner fiberglass as well so
it's a win-win then there's aluminum an
energy-intensive product made from
bauxite canada alone produces close to 3
million tons of aluminum annually
currently loading a 45-ton haul truck
hudson resources says using an orthosite
in the production can reduce the
environmental effects you end up with
about four tons of waste for every ton
of aluminum made and when you use an
ortho site you can produce zero waste
and so it is a truly a green green
product while any mining scars the
landscape greenland's government is
looking for minerals with low climate
impact and so far another site stands
out
even nasa wants to know more about the
benefits of mining anorthocyte because
the only larger deposits of the mineral
than here in greenland is on the moon
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm farah nasser thank you
so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your canada is
madeira park on bc's sunshine coast we
love seeing your canada so please email
us your pictures at viewers at
globalnational.com
nico garcia will be on the anchor desk
with you tomorrow until next time take
care of yourselves and each other
[Music]